If you wanna get really good at trading in 2024,
then I'm gonna show you
exactly what you need to focus on.
There are just four movements in the market
that you need to be concerned about.
Accumulation,
manipulation,
distribution,
and your expansion.
When price accumulates,
you can then expect manipulation in the market,
which is price taking out liquidity.
Once the manipulation phase has ended,
you can then expect
distribution from that manipulation area,
followed by an expansion of price
where price will either continue in that direction
or begin a reversal.
You can split this into separate cycles.
If you get really good at understanding time and price,
you'll be able to predict in the market
when each cycle is going to begin
its current move in the market.
But here we have consolidation of price.
Price then manipulates by sweeping this high.
Price then breaks structure to the downside.
Distributing from the manipulation phase,
coming back into the imbalance
which was created
to then continue in its intended direction. Cumulation,
manipulation,
distribution
and continuation.
Focus on those four movements in that order,
and you will start getting really,
really precise entries.